my name is Stuart Kim I'm a professor in
developmental biology and the Department
of Genetics at Stanford University while
I was a graduate student at Cal Tech
where i worked with lee hood and barbara
wold on antibody jeans and oncogenes in
mice then i went to work with bob
Horvitz at MIT to work on the nematode c
elegans and the genetics of cell lineage
and was fortunate enough to get a job
offer at stanford and i've been here
since then what's interesting about
personalized medicine is that the DNA
information that's published
continuously now can be used almost
immediately for you what's interesting
is that there's a real opportunity
because it's not being used by people I
would say as much as it could use though
there's eight thousand different DNA
variants and 1,200 different types of
trades and diseases that people could
know about themselves for free
immediately as long as you have your
genetic information which not only cause
eighty dollars so i think it's here as
long as it could be implemented and what
the country could do is figure out ways
to implement this information to help
people and prevent disease
you